hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge and surprise surprise I'm not
dead I was working on a very personal
project that you guys are gonna see
tomorrow but it was one of those things
that took longer than expected because
it was one of those things it just takes
as long as it needs to and it's not
really dependent on what's going on but
I went in a cave I turned off my phone I
didn't see anything so for all I know
the world that has exploded I have no
idea anymore but it's time to laugh away
my miseries in the end of the world with
some hilarious videos of which I'm going
to laugh at very hardly and I mean
hardly laugh at that's what I meant
[Music]
happy birthday Nate love mom and pop
what a wholesome family what an
unbelievable wholesome family what an
adorable way to celebrate a birthday
[Applause]
something wrong with that
sheep RAM Maram Rams the right word
ramrod I don't like where this going I
hate nudity mmm
makes me grumbled not funny I don't even
know what that was but that is not funny
alright I'm ready to be impressed
all right
[Music]
nope smiling is not laughing your home
and prevents yourself
mistakes happen for example if you're
trying to put a picture frame up there
on the wall
Oh Frick you like jazz I mom why did you
nope little [ __ ] fair
[Music]
no just clever not fun Hey
[Laughter]
well I lost just a few more I just never
expect them to be so quick cuz I hide
the length of the video for me so I
don't know if it's gonna be a first
[Laughter]
all right well that's the end of the
road for me I I made it pretty far in
that I made it exactly as far as I
always do but anyway that is the try not
to laugh challenge I'm probably not
gonna do another one for a while I'm
gonna stockpile more videos I've done a
few every week for the past few weeks
but tomorrow is I it should be ready I'm
not gonna say what it is it's something
that's I don't know it's something that
I wanted to do very much and it's
turning out okay and hopefully it's not
crap so that's all I have to say about
that
so thank you everybody so much for
watching remember the tour ticket sales
are still going on there's now a
convenient bar down there that takes you
right to where the nearest show is is
pretty cool so check it out down there
in the description and thank you
everybody for watching let me know if
you won let me know if you laughs let me
know if you didn't let me know if any of
these were funny at all to you so thanks
again and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye bye